[MUSIC PLAYING]
TYLER AKIDAU: Tyler Akidau.
I'm a software
engineer at Google
and also a member of the
Apache Beam Project Management
Committee.
LOIC JAURES: Hello.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Loic Jaures, and
I'm the co-founder and CTO
of Teads, which is a
video advertising company.
And we're here today to
talk to you about easily
moving back and forth between
batch and stream processing
pipelines, depending on the
characteristics, business
needs, et cetera,
of that pipeline.
TYLER AKIDAU: So as far
as our agenda goes today,
I'm going to do the first half.
And then Loic will
take over after that.
In the first half, I'm going to
cover, basically, Unified Model
fundamentals within Cloud
Dataflow and Apache Beam
that make it possible
to easily switch
between batch and
streaming mode,
depending on whatever
your use case is.
So it's going to be
four man sections there.
One is I'm going to define what
do we mean by Unified Model.
After that I'm going to
go into the infinite,
out-of-order data
sets that really
underlie the whole reason that
we need this Unified Model.
I'm going to spend a bunch of
time talking about the What,
Where, When, and How
model that really
enables this sort of thing.
And then I'll finish
up by summarizing
how all this conceptual,
theoretical stuff
enables batch and
streaming interoperability.
And then hand off to Loic.
LOIC JAURES: And I will discuss
about what we do at Teads,
namely analyzing 30
billion events per day.
And for that, I will
start by talking
a bit about Teads, the company,
who we are and what we do.
Then I will explain
the architecture
we use for the past three
years with the issues
and limitations we
face and the reason why
we moved to a new solution.
And I will describe
this new solution
and give you a few lessons
that we learned along the way.
TYLER AKIDAU: All
right, thank you.
So with that, I'll go
ahead and get started.
So before I actually dive
into the stuff I talked about
in the agenda, I want to
clarify up-front the systems
I'm going to be talking about.
So everything we're
talking about here
was originally part of Google
Cloud Dataflow, the system
that we launched back in 2015.
But about a year
ago, we actually--
so there's two things that
are in Cloud Dataflow.
There's this programming
model and SDK.
So these are the APIs and the
conceptual way of building data
processing pipelines.
And then there's also
this managed service.
So this is the
execution engine that
runs your pipelines for you
once you've written them, right?
So about a year
ago, we split these
into two separate
projects, essentially.
So there's the programming
a model and SDK were donated
to the Apache
Software Foundation
as a fully community-drive
open source project.
And I'll be going into
some of the details
about why that happened today.
And then there's a
couple talks that I'll
reference later,
tomorrow, that are going
to go into much more
detail about the community
and the motivations behind
it and things like that.
And then the other portion, that
managed service portion that
lives within Google Cloud,
remain Google Cloud Dataflow.
So just so you have that
context as I talk about things,
you'll know what
I'm talking about.
So what do we mean
by a Unified Model?
So the beginnings of the
need for this Unified Model
really can trace
back to early 2011.
So in 2011 time frame,
stream processing
was just starting
to become a thing.
And one of the things that
happened was stream processing
systems at the time,
like Apache Storm,
was that they made
design decisions in order
to reduce latency.
That also reduced their ability
to provide correct results.
And so Nathan Marz, who wrote
this blog post, who is also
the creator of Apache Storm,
came up with this idea
that we'd like to have low
latency results of our system,
but we also want
them to be correct.
And our streaming systems
can't give us correctness.
So instead, why don't
we do this thing
on there called the
Lambda Architecture, which
is you've got your data
set on the left there
and you run it through some
sort of stream processing
system that gives you low
latency, but not really
correct, results like
Apache Storm on the bottom--
just calling it out because
it's Nathan's system.
And then you run it also through
a batch processing system
that gives you strong
consistency, like Apache
Hadoop on top.
You somehow merge the
results together at the end,
and you end up getting
what you want, right?
You want these low
latency results
that are eventually correct.
The downside is that you're
building and maintaining
and then somehow
merging the results
from two separate systems.
This is costly among
a ton of dimensions.
And so one of the
big goals we set out
to have with Cloud
Dataflow and then
Apache Beam was to come
up with this Unified
Model for doing this.
So let you write
your pipeline one
time in one way that lets you
take your data set and get
your low latency, but also
eventually correct, results.
But what also falls
out from this is then
once you've established
this system,
it also allows you to
choose the tradeoffs
that you want to make.
So if you're OK
in this situation,
using a batch processing
engine on the back end
and trading off some of that
latency for greater efficiency,
you can do that.
And so what you have is
you've got your Beam pipeline
you've written.
And you've got to run
it on something, right?
And so you can run
it on a batch system.
Or you can run it on
a streaming system.
The choice is up to you.
The big point is that you
get to make this informed
decision that lets
you know trade off
these tensions between balancing
correctness latency and cost.
And if you want to learn more
about the details of this,
we published a paper on
this at VLDB in 2013.
And so you can go look this
up, and read through it.
And see both the details
of the underlying model
and really the conceptual
motivations behind it.
But it's not just
about this trading off
between these different
tensions that really
motivated us to create Beam.
There's another
aspect of it that's
really important as well.
And that is this ability to
run your pipeline, really,
on any supported runner.
And so it's not just batch
or streaming, but really
the choice of whatever
execution engine is the best
for your specific use case.
And then, of course, you're
all here at this Google Cloud
conference.
Our goal, as Google Cloud
developer, or Google Cloud
Dataflow developers, is
to make Cloud Dataflow
the absolute best place
for you to go and run
your Beam pipelines.
Beam allows you to
have this open source
way of accessing Cloud
Dataflow that doesn't lock you
into Google Cloud.
It's that open cloud
motivation there.
And so you can come to Google.
You've written
your Beam pipeline.
You hand it off to
us in Cloud Dataflow.
And we run it through our
optimizer that comes up
with the best way
to run it possibly,
schedule [INAUDIBLE]
machines, brings up VMs,
integrates cleanly with all the
various portions of the Google
Cloud.
And all of this is done within
the managed service, where
you don't have to do
any of the ops work
to actually keep all
this up and running.
So that's the rough introduction
to what we meant by the Unified
Model and where it came from.
So next, let's look at
infinite, out-of-order data
sets, because these were
really the motivating reason
for needing this Unified Model.
So in order to do this, some
ground things in a concept--
a concrete example.
So imagine you are some startup.
You've created some
new cool mobile game
where users go on their
phones, and they crush candy
or kill orcs or whatever.
And as they do this,
you're collecting logs
about the things they're doing.
And through our example,
the biggest thing
is we're going to say, we're
collecting user scores, right?
And we want to be able to tally
up user scores and team scores
and basically analyze the
data and understand how
people are using our product.
So we start out with a data set.
So this is representing the
logs from our games, right?
And each of these little
squares is one user score.
And as our game
gets more popular,
our data set may get bigger.
And eventually it may
get so big that we
started organizing into some
sort of repeated structure,
right?
We start collecting
logs for a given day,
so Tuesdays logs
and Wednesdays logs.
But really this is
just a cheap way
of representing an
infinite data source.
The game logs are
continuous, so really you
want to treat them in
a continuous manner.
What's worse, because we're
dealing with the service
systems here, and we're
dealing with mobile devices,
there's ambiguity involved.
So let's look at a
few of these scores.
So we're going look at
three different scores
from different gamers that
all happened conceptually
at 8:00 AM.
So all of them were on
their phone at 8:00 AM
and made these scores.
So this first one, this red
one here, happened at 8:00 AM.
And you can see within our big,
unbounded, steam of data here,
it showed up pretty
close to 8:00 AM.
So that's great.
And then this yellow one,
it was delayed a little bit,
but it also showed up
roughly close to 8:00 AM.
But then somebody
representing this green square
was on a plane or
something in airplane mode,
and they'd scored
the score at 8:00
but it wasn't until
whatever that is-- five,
six hours later-- that they
actually took the phone out
of airplane mode and were
able to upload that score.
So this is what I mean when we
talk about out-of-order data
sets.
Conceptually, that score
happened back a lot closer
to where these two happened.
But we didn't learn about
it until hours later.
So now we got this
infinite unbounded
out-of-order data set.
How do we process it?
Well, there are a
few different ways
that you can approach
this depending
on what your pipeline's doing.
So the most simple,
simple kind are
element-wise transformations.
So with element-wise
transformations,
you're just doing things on
an element by element basis.
So in this case, we're basically
filtering out everything
except for the yellow elements.
You don't have to
look at anything other
than a single element
at any given time.
So it's relatively
straightforward.
Another way to do
this, once you start
wanting to do an
aggregation, you've
got to group your elements
together somehow over time.
So one way to do this
is to aggregate them
into processing time windows.
So you just basically
break apart time
as elements arrive as they're
observed in the stream,
and say, this is
my window of time.
I'm going to treat this as a
group of elements together.
It's the simplest way to do it.
But it also means if your
elements are arriving out
of order, they may be processed
within groups that they
don't really relate to.
So if you remember that
green element we had that
showed up way more, like 1
o'clock in the afternoon,
we would account that with
all these other events that
happened around 1:00
instead of with events
that happened around
8:00 like we should have.
So what we really
want when you're
dealing with out-of-order
data is event-time windowings.
So event-time windowing lets
you take this unordered steam
of data and, effectively,
perform a time-based shuffle
to put these elements that
arrive out of order back
into the order they should
have been and aggregate them
together with the elements
that they belong with.
But to do this, we
really need to formalize
the relationship between
processing time and event time.
So what we have here is a graph.
And we're going to actually
look at a bunch of graphs
throughout this presentation.
But on the x-axis,
we have event time.
So that's in blue.
So this is when the
events actually happen.
So the user's on their
phone, playing their game,
and they scored some points,
and they were recorded.
That's the event time.
The processing time is,
then, when the events show up
in the system.
We learn about them
and process them.
And that dash line up the
middle would be the ideal.
If events happened were
processed at the same time,
they'd all lie on that ideal.
But reality is a little
more like this red curve.
Because of distributed
systems, because of delays
and for mobile
phones, et cetera,
you get this wandering,
meandering line
that sometimes comes
close to the ideal
but oftentimes
skews away from it.
And really, this horizontal
distance between the ideal
and this red line, this
reference the skew and event
time.
So how far off are we
from the ideal as far as
completeness and event time?
And in order to reason about
completeness and correctness,
we need to be able to
understand where that skew is.
And so we do this was a
thing called a watermark.
And a watermark,
essentially, tries
to capture the notion
of this red line.
It describes progress of
event time completeness
within the system.
It's roughly a guarantee
that no time stamp
earlier than the watermark
will ever be seen again.
Now, you can actually have
two types of watermarks,
depending on what
your input source is.
If you have complete knowledge
about your input source,
you're actually able to provide
a perfect watermark, which
means this literally
is a guarantee.
You will never see a time stamp
earlier than the watermark.
Because we deal with
distributed systems or systems,
like in our case where
we are reading from--
accepting mobile
phone scores, we
have no way of knowing all
the mobile phones out there
that might be having scores
made on them at a given time
and then uploaded later.
In that case, you often
have to create watermarks
that are heuristic-based.
So you take all the information
and make the best estimate you
can of what the watermark is.
And then, in that case,
you may actually be wrong,
and you'll have
to deal with that.
So there's two problems,
then, that are listed here
at the bottom with watermarks.
One is that they
can be too slow.
If you're accurately
holding back the watermark
because you know there's
late data, that's fine.
But it also is--
you're essentially holding
back progress of the system,
waiting for these records
that you know are late.
The other is that
they can be too fast.
So the case of
having a heuristic
watermark, if your
heuristic is wrong,
if your guess is
off, you'll say,
oh yeah, the watermark has
advanced to time x but stuff
with time stamp before
x may show up later.
So that's a case of
it being too late.
So we'll look at ways that we
address this in the future.
But that leads us to
this next section.
So how do we deal
with these issues?
Well, it's not quite so
hard if you actually know
what kinds of questions to ask.
So what we've done with
Apache Beam and Cloud Dataflow
is try to provide a system that
lets you think about your data
processing problem by answering
these four simple questions.
So what is it that
you're computing?
Are you creating sums,
or are you doing joins,
or are you building histograms,
machine learning models?
This is the question that you've
traditionally probably thought
about answering with
classic batch processing.
But beyond that, when
you want to start
dealing with these
unbounded data sets,
there's a few other questions
you want to start answering.
So where in event time are
you actually performing
these calculations?
Because when you have this
infinite, unbounded data set,
you can't just
assume that you'll
wait till you see the end of
it because there may be no end.
You're going to have
to chop it up some way.
And then after
you've defined where
an event time this is happening,
when in processing time
do you actually
emit results for it?
Do you wait until you think
your inputs are complete?
Do you want to give speculative
results over time that
show your answers evolving?
And, in cases where
you have late data,
what do you do if
data show up late?
Do you throw them away?
Do you incorporate them in?
How do you deal with this?
And lastly then, in
cases where you do
provide multiple results,
how do those refinements
of those results
relate over time?
So we're going to go
now through examples
of each of those questions and
see what I mean in more detail.
So for the what question,
what are you computing,
we talked previously
about there's
element-wise operations.
There's aggregations.
There's also this notion within
Beam of composite operations.
So taking a set of more
primitive operations
and turning them into
a higher-level concept,
like a sum, right, which is a
grouping and then an addition
operation, or deduction.
So, for our example, we're going
to look through some code here.
This is pseudo Java because
it needs to fit on slides.
And we're going to elide
a lot of this as we go.
The basic idea is we're
reading some log lines.
So that's the first line.
We're reading them
into a PCollection.
The PCollection is
the Beam and Dataflow
notion of a massive, potentially
massive, collection of data.
Then we're going to apply
these transformations to it.
So first we're going to
apply a parser that's
going to parse it into this
key-value pairs of strings
and integers.
So users are going to
be team-score pairs
because we're going to want
to compute team scores here.
And then, lastly,
we're going to apply
this composite
Sum.integersPerKey
operation, which is
just going to compute
these per-team scores for us.
And so for each of these
examples, we're going to have,
again, an event time on
the x-axis, green y-axis,
processing time graph.
And each of these circles
here represents a single score
from a single user
on the same team.
We're looking at
one team at a time,
just because otherwise it
would be three-dimensional,
and this is enough to deal with.
And so this dashed line
will represent that ideal.
If you remember from the
watermarks slide I had earlier,
and you can see where these
relate relative to that ideal.
This score of three is really
close-- relatively close to it.
So it happened around--
what is it?
I can't tell from
here-- almost 12:07,
and it arrived not too
shortly thereafter.
But then you've got
this nine example.
This one actually
showed up quite a while
after the event
actually happens.
So you can see there's that much
greater skew from the ideal.
And so we're going to look at
a few different animations.
So this is just the
initial pipeline
we talked about where we read in
data and then we compute a sum.
And so what's happening here is
there's this thick, thick line
coming from the bottom.
And the animation just loops, so
you can watch it over and over.
This thick, white line
ascending up the bottom
represents time as we observe
it as the pipeline observes
these data coming in.
So as the line reaches
one of the elements,
it's basically
seeing that element
and incorporating it
into the sum, which
you can see accumulating
there in the middle.
And once it gets to the
top, it computes its answer.
And the rectangle turns blue,
and it materializes the result,
right?
So this is pretty
standard batch processing.
So let's make it a
little more interesting
and move forward and start
answering some more questions.
So the first question
I want to touch on is
where in event time.
So the answer to the where
question is windowing.
So windowing is a way
of dividing data up
into event-time,
finite-based chunks.
So this lets you get
your temporal chunking
within the data, within
this infinite data stream,
so that you can know
where you're actually
calculating within a
finite set of the data.
There's a number of different
examples of types of windowing.
I have three up here--
fixed windows, where you
basically just slice up
the data into fixed, say, hourly
windows or 10-minute windows.
Sliding is a lot like fixed
except you slide a little bit
each time.
And so the interesting
thing there
is that the windows
start to overlap.
And sessions are a very
interesting example
of windowing that we
won't go into detail here.
But basically, they're based
of the data themselves.
So you can't know ahead
of time what sessions are.
They actually try to capture
some quality of the data
itself.
So usually it's defined as
you see a sequence of activity
for a given key, like
for a given user,
they're active on your
website and you group them
into groups of activity
that then terminate
when the user stops interacting
with your service or whatever.
So you can see these bursts
of activity of a user,
and they allow you to reason
about engagement levels
and things like that.
So they're very powerful
and very interesting.
But let's go ahead and add some
windowing to our pipeline here.
So in order to do that in Beam,
you just simply add this window
transform.
And it reads quite plainly--
window into fix windows
of two minutes long.
And so if we then go back
to our animated example,
again running this
on a batch system,
you can see instead of
accumulating a single result,
we've now sliced it up
into two-minute slices
of event time.
So in this case, we're looking
at about nine minutes of data.
So we end up with
four different scores
across four two-minute windows.
And again, as before,
this is a batch pipeline,
so we wait until we've
seen all the data
and get our results at the end.
But the whole point
of this talk is
this talk about
being able to switch
between batch and streaming.
So let's see what it takes,
then, to then take this
and move it into streaming.
So once we want to
move into streaming,
we can't wait until we've
seen all of the input
in order to produce
results so we've
got to somehow figure out
a way of producing results
earlier than that.
And that's when we
start to answer the
when question-- when
in processing time
do we materialize these results?
And we do that with this
thing called triggers.
So triggers control when
results are emitted.
So what we'll do
to begin with is
we'll add a trigger
that says we're
going to trigger when
the watermark passes
the end of the window.
This is effectively
the default trigger,
so we wouldn't need
to specify this.
You could actually use the
code from the previous example
in a streaming pipeline
and get this effect.
And this is also,
effectively, the same thing
that's happening when
you run in batch mode.
But if we do this in
a streaming example,
then, we'll look first here at
a perfect watermark example.
So in this case,
we have a watermark
represented by that
dashed screen line, which
is a perfect watermark.
So it's going to guarantee us
that we never see late data.
And basically what
happens is the system
waits until the watermark
passes the end of the window.
And once it does,
it knows, OK, I'm
never going to see any
more data for this window,
so it's OK to go ahead and
materialize the result for it.
So you see, as before, we
get our four results of 14,
22 3, and 12, but it does so
in this incremental fashion
as the data for those
windows become complete.
And in this way, allows
you to continually process
an unbounded stream of
data and give results
that come out as they go.
Now let's look at another
example here next to it
of a heuristic watermark.
So let's imagine we have a
watermark that's not perfect.
And as you can see, it looks
different than the dashed one.
This solid green watermark
is a little more aggressive
and it actually gets it wrong.
It doesn't know about that nine
that ends up showing up late.
And so what happens here
is that time progresses on.
And we emit our
windows as they come.
But in that first
window, it thought
it was complete when
it saw the five,
and the watermark advanced.
And then later,
along came the nine,
and there's nothing the
system could do about it.
It had already produced results,
so we got the wrong answer.
We said five.
The answer should
have actually been 14.
So how can we deal with that?
So triggers provide
ways to deal with this.
So in this case we
can make our trigger
a little more complex to
deal with the subtleties
of our specific data set.
So in this case,
we've added two new--
two modifications to
the watermark trigger.
We've said, well, we want
early firings every minute
of processing time.
So this is basically going to
give us speculative results
as our data evolve.
And then, also, to deal
with things like that
late nine that showed
up, we're going to say,
if we ever get late
data, we're going
to go ahead and trigger a
firing again anytime we see one.
We don't expect a
whole lot of data.
So we'll just do it anytime we
see an element count of one.
And that way, we will account
for these late records showing
up.
So if we then use
this trigger, we
can see that our two
examples now look like this.
The nice thing here is that
in the heuristic watermark
case, when that late nine shows
up, you can see we go ahead
and incorporate it.
And it gets incorporated
into a late result.
And each of the panes here is
annotated with whether it's
an early result are an on-time
results or late results.
Another interesting
feature of this you can see
is that it helps with that
too slow problem of watermarks
that we talked about earlier.
So without the
early watermark, you
had to wait almost
10 minutes to get
an answer of that first window
in the perfect watermark case.
Even though you knew it
was at least five early
on, whereas with this additional
early trigger that we put
in here, you start to get these
speculative results to let
you see your results
build up over time.
So that brings us to
the last question here.
So how do refinements relate?
When we start having multiple
panes within a window,
how did those panes
relate to each other?
So we're going to look
through an example
here where we're going
to have three trigger
firings, a speculative
firing, a watermark
firing, and a late firing.
And for each of
those, you can see
which elements have showed up.
So the speculative firing
will include a value of three.
The watermark firing will
include a five and a one.
And then we'll get a late
firing with a value of two.
And we'll look at each of
the three different modes
that we have here to
deal with defining
how refinements relate.
So the first one
is discarding mode.
Or another way to think
of it is a delta mode.
So when the trigger
fires, we throw away
whatever state we've built up,
whatever sum we've accumulated,
and start over again from zero.
And so you end up
with these panes--
three, six, and two--
that don't really relate
to each other in any way.
In the last observed value, it
has nothing to do with the sum,
even though we're going
to be computing sums.
But if you sum them
up individually,
you do get the final sum.
This is useful for cases where
your outputs are actually
going into another system that's
doing some further aggregation.
The second one, which is
what we've seen all along,
is accumulating mode, which
actually holds onto that state
that you see.
You can think of this
as, maybe, a value mode.
It gives you the current
value every time.
So we see three first time,
then five and one show up.
You add those together, and the
next time the value is nine.
So every time, you
can just replace
the previous value with the new
value to get what is current.
And so that's why you
see the last observed
there is 11 at the end.
It gives you that
correct result.
The downside with this
system is if you actually
sum those up themselves,
you double count.
So you have to
make sure that this
is used in a system
where you can overwrite
previous values
where there's not
going to be any accumulation.
The one you really want, which
we don't have quite implemented
yet, but is accumulating
and retracting mode,
which gives you, essentially,
accumulating mode,
but also every time it
gives you a new value,
it gives you a retraction
for the previous value.
It says, with that
on-time firing, it says,
well, previously I'd
said the value was three.
Well, take that away,
retract that, and also
here's the new value of nine.
So that allows you
to, in situations
where there may be further
aggregations down the pipeline,
you can actually get the
correct result that way.
Or if you just look at the last
observed non-retraction value,
you also get the correct result.
So we'll look real quickly at
what adding a retracting mode
does to the pipeline.
So this is our same
example from before.
But now every time we
fire a non-initial pane,
you see we get two panes.
We get both the new
result in yellow and then
also this retraction
in red that's saying,
the previous value
that I told you before,
well, go ahead and get rid
of that, because I was wrong.
And that allows you to really
properly update results
over time, even without having
to just blindly overwrite
a previous value.
All right, so before
I hand off to Loic
to hear about a more
concrete example of this,
I want to talk very quickly
about how all this enables
batch and streaming interop.
So it really comes
down to two things that
are provided by the system--
this ability for
correctness in light
of changing inputs or
different types of inputs
and in different ways of
processing those inputs
under the covers, and
then the flexibility
afforded by the model
to make those choices.
So on the correctness
front, we've
talked about distributed systems
and how they're distributed
and you never know what
you're going to get.
So to really
quantify this for us,
let's look at two
examples of how we might
have observed these events.
So you can see they're
shifting up and down
between this white set of input
records and this purple set.
You'll notice that they
aren't shifting on the x-axis.
These are the same events.
They happened at the same time.
We're just changing the order
in which we observe them
within the pipeline.
We're changing their
processing time.
So if we were to process these
records using processing time
windows where you just
view them as they come in,
what effectively is happening
is you're taking those events,
you're throwing
away the event time,
and you're shifting
them onto the ideal.
You're saying, when
I saw this event,
I'm going to treat that as
its position in the window.
So you're-- I seem to have--
you're mapping processing time
onto event time and
then summing things up.
And you can see when
you change the ordering,
then you get different results.
So the first window
in order number
one, you get a result of 12.
And ordering two,
you get a result
of seven, which
isn't what you want.
Whereas if you use event time
windowing, where you actually
aggregate and
process these events
within the event-time
windows when they happened,
you get the same
result no matter
what the processing
time ordering.
Now the actual shape of results
over time as they evolve
may be different.
And that's just a characteristic
of how your data arrive.
But at the end of the day, you
come up with the same results.
And this is a key part of how
you can provide a system that
operates the same even
if it's in streaming mode
or in batch mode.
The second part is flexibility.
So the five examples
we've walked through,
you can see how the
system gives you
the flexibility to
choose the ones that
work for your use case.
And specifically,
when we're talking
about switching between
batch and streaming,
there were three cases
there that they gave me
the same final results no
matter whether it was batch mode
or in streaming mode.
And if you don't care about late
data, really, there were four.
And we did this with
relatively minor code changes.
I don't expect you to
be able to read this.
But the point is
that we didn't make
a whole lot of different changes
to fit these different use
cases.
And the really
important point is
that we never changed
our core algorithm,
that sum of integers per key.
And this is true no matter
how complex your algorithm is.
You define what it
is you're computing,
and then everything else you may
need to change in slight ways
to tweak it for
batch or streaming,
is totally independent of
that, which really gives you
the flexibility to cleanly
switch between the two.
So I've now given you the
theoretical, conceptual
foundation for why we can
support this switching
between batch and streaming.
I'm going to now
hand off to Loic,
who's going to give you a little
more concrete details of how
they've done that with
their system at Teads.
LOIC JAURES: Thank you.
Thank you, Tyler.
So yeah, you're right.
The proposal of
my talk today was
going to be to
give you a feedback
of our usage of Dataflow
but also BigQuery
and more broadly about GCP.
So as I mentioned
in the intro, we'll
start by talking
a bit about Teads.
So we created Teads in 2011.
And we now have 27 offices
in 21 countries in the world.
Last year we achieved
200 million of revenues.
We have 500 employees, and
among them, 90 plus of them
are from the R&D team.
And what we do, we try to solve,
measure issue this advertising
industry has, which is the
scarcity of premium video
inventory.
Only 5% of online video
inventory is premium.
So we've created a
format to fix this issue.
So I have a quick video to show
you, the formats in action.
All right, OK.
So this is the inRead.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So you probably came
across this format.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So it's a way to embed video
within editorial content.
So as you can see, the video
is paused when it's not visible
and displaying only
when it is visible.
And you can tap on the ad to see
it full screen with sound on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, so let's move on
to the next slide.
With this simple
format, in fact,
we've been able to solve
issue for the three
main actors of this industry.
So first the publishers.
There's a lot of
publishers that they
have a lot of textual content.
And they want to monetize
this content through video.
So with this format from
one day to the other one,
they could monetize all
that content with video.
For advertisers,
they want to have
viewable ad, which is what's
the inRead does by design.
And they want to be displayed
within premium content, which
we bring with the
publishers that we have.
And finally the
publishers-- the users.
We try to create the
formats in such a way which
is not intrusive, which
is engaging for our user.
And this way, you can skip the
ad if you're not interested.
Or you can activate a
song if you are interested
and only if you are
interested in the ad.
It's not working.
So today we are the number one
video marketplace in the world.
And we can see on this graph
the growth that we have.
During the past years,
starting in 2012 until now,
today we reach more than 1.2
billion users every month.
So we're also within
the club of websites
reaching more than
one billion users.
So the question is what do
we do with this kind of data?
So nothing fancy here.
We do BI for internal purpose.
We do, also, analytics.
So we provide publishers and
advertisers with a dashboard
so they can understand
their website.
They can understand how
their ads are performing.
We optimize our algorithm
through machine learning.
And I have few of
those use cases.
But the last one I would like
to mention is fraud detection.
So we started in 2012,
and as Tyler mentioned,
back then the code from
Nathan Marz was the reference.
And basically Nathan is
explaining in these codes
that the system has
two main features.
The first one is the storage.
We need to ingest all the data.
And the second one is the
way we retrieve and bring
the result to the end users.
But we have to keep in mind
that this kind of system
of a lifetime, which
is pretty long.
So for us, our system is running
for six years and even more.
And therefore, we
need to find a way
to overcome any kind of hardware
failure that could occur.
Any kind of human mistakes, even
though we try to avoid them,
sometimes it happens.
So that's why it's really
crucial to store raw data.
And once you have raw
data, you can simply
apply a function to it.
And you can have
your end result.
So this is perfect,
but the issue
is that all data means
a few petabytes of data.
So it's not applicable
in real life.
So to solve this issue,
you need to create
some views, pre-computed views,
to accelerate the queries.
So every time you have a new
use case, a new client asking
for something, you need
to create a new view
to support this new use case.
So we ended up operating and
managing Lambda architecture.
So this is Lambda
architecture by the book.
And for us, we are using--
we were using
Amazon Web Services.
So we are using Kafka
for the queue messaging.
Then the data as two ways.
The first one for the batch
layer, so the first step
is to store the data
so we can be safe.
And the data is there.
So for that, we use what
we call the fetcher,
and we store data on S3.
And then the batch mode is
computing all these views
on these rollups.
And we used to do
it in MapReduce,
then we moved to Spark.
And we store the end
result in Cassandra.
On the bottom of these charts,
you have the speed layer.
So for that, we use Storm.
And once again the data
is outputted in Cassandra.
And for the final result,
we are using a tool
that we call reporting.
That's merged in the data.
So if the data is
available in batch mode,
we are taking this one.
Otherwise we offer backing on
the real-time data that has
been computed through Storm.
So this kind of
architecture is pretty great
because you can fix
any kind of issues.
If you have stored the data, you
can recreate it from scratch.
So you just discard
the batch data.
And then use the raw data
to compute the new views.
And you're fine again.
You fix the issues.
And cherry on the cake, you
can even create view for needs
you didn't think of
previously because you
have the data to support this.
Few numbers.
So I should have mentioned
that we are using
Hadoop for both the Spark jobs.
And then to use the reporting,
so there's two [? uses ?]
for the Hadoop cluster.
We have a Hadoop cluster
of around 120 nodes.
Our Cassandra cluster
is around 60 nodes.
And we ingest, everyday,
around 4 terabytes of data.
And this is done only with
a team of three people.
So with this kind of scale,
you start to face limitations.
So just to name a few.
The number of views
you need to create
to support all your client
needs, then to grow very fast,
so you have to
create a lot of them.
And therefore, when
there's a mistake,
and you need to recompute
all those views,
it's quite expensive.
You also need to create
some internal jobs to add
some steps to bring
the end result.
And therefore you ended up
with a lot of complexity.
And finally, not the
least, because you
are managing those big clusters,
it involves a lot of work
in terms of monitoring,
automation, and so on.
So it doesn't scale magically.
So we started to think about
an ideal solution for us, which
would be using only one
single unified view.
And therefore with
this view, we could
have all the
combinations possible
and combine all the
dimensions with bits.
We wanted it to be
really fast to be
able to compute those
views in minutes, not days.
And finally, if possible,
it would be manageable,
more manageable than
the previous system.
And why not managed by someone
else, if you see what I mean.
So that's why we tried to
run a POC with BigQuery.
So as our data are
were lying on the S3,
we just transferred the data
to GCP using data transfer.
And then, because at the time
the packet was not supported,
we added a step with Dataproc
to convert data and ingest
the data in the query.
So since then, packet
support has been developed.
So it will be easier
if I to do is it now.
Once you have the data, you
can try to play with it.
And to create this unified
view, we were eager to have.
So this is how the data looks
like when we try to ingest it.
There's basically a
timestamp and a few IDs.
So advertisement ID, website ID.
There's tons of them.
And finally, there's the event.
So the first thing we can do
is try to compress the data,
because we do not provide
reports per minute
but per hour.
So we could get rid
of the timestamped
and replace it by the
hour plus a counter.
So this is the first
step, which is fine.
But we can go even deeper.
Something we want to do is
to use a dedicated column
for every kind of
event that we can have.
So have a column for
impression, a column for start,
and finally, there's
one for clicks.
And this way, we can go from
four rows in the first example
to only one with three counters,
two impressions, one start,
and one click.
And you can leverage the
columnar storage system
of BigQuery, because if you
want to query only impressions,
you can just read
those integers instead
of having to scroll and read
a string, which is way faster.
And as the data
is quite similar,
it's a good use case
for compression.
So this way, we've been
[INAUDIBLE] to compressed data
by 70x.
And we try to run query to it.
So we've been impressed by
the performance of BigQuery.
And we, in fact, achieved better
results and better performance
on this hourly rollup
than the previous system,
even though it was
optimized for query.
So with this
success, we moved on
to the next step, which
involved Dataflow, which is
the live ingestion of the data.
So as we have in this
queue messaging, Kafka,
we just plugged Dataflow to it.
So keep in mind that we are
using two different cloud
providers.
So Dataflow is responsible
to retrieve the data to a AWS
from AWS and to
insert it in BigQuery.
So it was really,
really easy to do
because we perform very few
modifications on the data,
and it was working fine.
But there's a few challenges
that we would like to discuss.
The first one is, I
think, pretty obvious.
I think two clouds adds
a bit of complexity.
So we need to handle this.
We need to avoid creating
the same stuff plenty times.
So for instance, we
have all your rights
on one cloud provider and the
same one on the second one.
That needs to be kept in sync.
Same goes for network
configuration and so on.
So we are investing
a lot in Terraform.
And I think you should do the
same if even though you only
operate on one cloud provider,
its a good use of your time.
And second issue
that we faced is not
really linked to Dataflow
but more to BigQuery.
So Dataflow is really
fast and pretty cheap,
but when you are trying
to ingest raw data, which
means more terabytes per day,
the streaming mode of BigQuery
could be a bit expensive.
And we start to think
about those questions
that we mentioned.
Do we need to go
to stream or batch?
And we acknowledged that
it was not the right use
case for the streaming mode.
So we switched to what
we call the micro batch,
meaning batched
every 15 minutes,
which is fine for our use case.
And we also think about
all the solutions,
like sampling the data when it's
technical metrics when you just
need the trend and not exact
value and this kind of stuff.
So this is the end result.
You have your timeline
with the events.
The color is representing
the hour of [INAUDIBLE].
So for us, its mostly
[? ordered fine, ?]
but you could have late events.
And we just read
a batch of data,
a chunk of data using Dataflow
and write it to BigQuery.
So without a lot
of modifications,
just a few checks, and casting.
And then we are
leveraging the SQL power,
and we create those
rollups I mentioned before.
And we are separating the
data out from the hour of 7:00
AM from 8:00 AM.
And we write those in
two different tables.
And then, as time
goes by, there's
new events that need
to be processed.
So first step, ingestion
on BigQuery using Dataflow.
And then we append the data.
And you can see.
I guess you've
understood the principle.
OK, so this is the overview
and the final architecture.
So Kafka, Dataflow consuming the
data, writing it to BigQuery,
then applying SQL query
to generate those rollups.
And we can go even
deeper with new queries
to create specialized data
marts for specific needs in case
we need those.
So I just want to go back.
I mentioned this before,
the fraud detections.
So right now, we have a
loop, which is every hour.
We are retrieving the data.
We are checking
to see if there's
any fraud or anomaly detections.
And we think this is
a perfect use case
to leverage the streaming
mode of Dataflow
and try to speed up a bit this
feedback loop to have faster
feedback results.
So in terms of
results, we've been
able to shrink our cluster.
So the Hadoop cluster, or
the equivalent of Hadoop,
goes from 120 nodes to 32 nodes.
We no longer need
Cassandra, and we are using
BigQuery, which is managed.
So no nodes to manage.
You can see there's
more data on BigQuery
because we do no longer need
to discard the raw data.
And we can keep it on BigQuery
and use it when we need it.
Volume's the same.
Team size is the same.
And the POC plus the PILOT has
been done in only four months.
So a few more slides.
In terms of scale, we
were reaching the limits.
We were wondering if it
was possible to scale
to the next level because
it took us around 40 minutes
to compute one hour of data.
So we were wondering if
it was possible to scale.
And now we know for
sure that's the case
because we tried with
10 times more data,
and it's working fine.
And in fact, the times
to process one hour data
have been down to
only four minutes.
So full batch of one
minute, four minutes,
which is impressive.
In terms of costs, it used to
require a lot of maintenance
to handle all
those big clusters.
And it was pretty expensive.
So now we've delegated,
basically, all these jobs
to BigQuery and to Google.
So it's managed for us.
So the cost of operations
have been down close to zero.
And we're all now under
control regarding the cost.
Something I would
like to mention
is that the cost been reduced
even though we have around 20%
of the overall cost,
which is the egress
to transfer the data from
one cloud to the other one.
So there's room
for optimisation.
In terms of complexity,
instead of having
to chain all those long jobs
and manage a role and retries,
we just have only two steps--
ingest data and do the rollups.
And the data is now actionable
because it no longer
requires you to write Spark jobs
or complicated stuff like that.
You can just leverage
the SQL query.
So basically anyone
with basic SQL knowledge
could leverage the
data and use it.
And finally, we are
having a single rollup
instead of partial rollups.
So we can combine everything.
And we can combine
all the dimensions
and answer questions we were
not able to answer previously.
And I would like to
conclude this thought
by congratulating the wonderful
team that worked on this.
So this is the [INAUDIBLE].
And thank you for them.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]